the Joe Rogan experience your three oh
you mean how he's into cars this week
next week sees me in trolls me one chop
his dick off well they were like this
article was like really super positive
about it like bringing the kid to
therapy and [ __ ] and aiding his
transition like he's [ __ ] three and
this I just read this like two days ago
I was like this is so nuts there's so
much of this going on right now yeah and
I want to be a transformer with us three
you don't see my dad putting [ __ ]
mechanical arms on me imagine I was
three arms I mean I'm 19 like what the
[ __ ] dad why am i a robot now well when
you're three told you want to be a robot
that's the same [ __ ] it's the same [ __ ]
it's correct it's insane it's so weird
it's so weird that people are just
openly jumping into this and it's these
weirdo super you know ideological
progressive people that just they're
locked into this idea that it's amazing
to have a trans kid and you know the kid
shows any sign whatsoever being
inclining to be female or inclined to be
male that they're pushing it I feel like
this is actually bad out here
well it's also very dangerous because
they start wanting to [ __ ] with the kids
hormones like you gotta let the the
child develop there's no real science
and what the [ __ ] happens when you put
hormone blockers into a three-year-old
and try to transition them into a girl
but also the the real doctors you know
what the hell they're doing they're not
gonna inject that kid with hormones
they're gonna say listen if you want to
do this when you're 18 19 even then it's
a little too early but nice do you know
when you're 21 which is against you
early that and I've seen this on some of
the [ __ ] reality TV shows i watch
but these legit dogs go then I'm willing
to help you out but before then get out
of here no get out let's see where yet
when you're 16 there's a market for it
which is a cruel thing to say and a
weird way to describe it here's the
problem Jon we're talking about you know
on the spectrum for some of those kids
they do feel like they're trapped on
woman's body you know and I feel for him
that must suck to go through high school
and all that but isn't that the
exception you know I'm saying like it is
that kid the exception that follow and
they should have access to it how could
you do that with a three-year-old I know
I mean how do you know I mean you just
don't and anybody says he do you're
crazy
people change you changed when hormones
get into your body and maybe you won't
be the most masculine man in the world
and maybe you
we'll turn into a woman someday maybe
but give yourself a goddamn chance that
just exists
did you see the high school wrestler yes
the girl just beaten the break in that
bin and she later cast booze like a
[ __ ] she does I know it's not
fair she should be able out to wrestle
ball or he should be allowed to wrestle
voice you know but you know whatever man
it's crazy you're taking a high school
girl and you're filling her up with
testosterone with injections what it's
not allowing you to wrestle girls that
aren't on testosterone
it's [ __ ] cheating okay if she was
just a girl and she wasn't like trying
to transition into a man and they found
out that she was winning the state
championship as a woman or as a girl
rather by taking steroids they would
take it away from oh they would say
she's cheating should they be there be
an uproar but not let her wrestle yes
not let her rest
don't let her rest at all what if they
go we can't wrestle with the boys and
they just can't rest at all well this
rest of the boys
don't wrestle I would say she that's
what she wants
you know what's rest of the boys she
gonna answer that either the zero losers
yeah I think hey if you if you're gonna
choose to go that path of this
transition into a female then you give
up your right to wrestle because we
don't have a division for that debt and
yeah we don't have enough wrestle yeah
she's transitioning to he and it's just
it's not fair if it was the other way it
would be more fair because like if
you're a man and you're transitioning to
be a woman and they make you wrestle men
well you're gonna be at a disadvantage
because you are taking hormone blockers
or you're getting castrated you're
losing your testicles you whatever
whatever it is you are at a disadvantage
you get that aspect yeah he's at a
disadvantage now transitioning to I mean
he's added a massive utage right now
transitioning to a man say he's on
steroids the gun up the kids on stress
test 100% and play a lot of probably a
lot of it because they're trying to turn
him into a man correct it's all nuts I
know like where was this 30 years ago it
was it's like a silent epidemic there's
everyone just I was covered and like god
I feel like a woman you know there was a
few of those there was like that one guy
renee Richards that the tennis player
that
transitioning he was a terrible male
tennis player transitioned to a female
tennis player and started dominating on
us you that's Juwanna Mann that's the
plot of Juwanna Mann tennis edition
movie no what do you wanna do wanna man
was a guy who couldn't get suspended
from like the Lakers the fake Lakers in
the movie so he's like God I won't play
basketball so like you could make the
women's team you just wore a wig and put
TVs on and start dunking on [ __ ] well
that does happen today there was a guy
who was ready for this 50 years old he
was six foot four five played women's
college basketball because he played as
a man but now he's not a man anymore
now this fool is a [ __ ] this fool
he's a fool he went back and you're 50
years old and you're pretending to be a
college girl he'll be like I'm in a
fantasy world this is my fantasy and
she's a giant and she's swatting
basketballs out of people's hands
this Juwanna Mann yeah see if you find
the guy who played it was 50 what type
in 50 year old transsexual man
transsexual plays women's college bath
in America right yeah in America well
here's the thing imagine if your kid is
on a team with that person and that
person takes your kids scholarship takes
your kids oh look at that right there
Oh seriously jack jacked and got 50
year-old nose on them and became a
college basketball player at [ __ ]
mind
get the [ __ ] out of here 52 excuse me
Gabriel Ludwig 52 okay two years old the
name goes to college entry ball I think
she played as a man look at the size
difference now imagine your kid is
competing against her and he can't get a
shot off it's just [ __ ] it's like if
Shaquille O'Neal was playing on that
other team if Shaquille O'Neal
transitioned to be a woman and decided
to go back to college this College would
let her play as a woman that Shaquille
O'Neal as a woman what college is that
douche bag University I don't know I
don't want to I don't want to give him
any press Perez this makes me sick
I mean that's a giant nonsense with it
it's straight nonsense it's straight
nonsense this is where she good Paul
place is that this is where
progressiveness goes down the rabbit
hole
what is it mission College let's write a
JUCO huh
I don't know what it is but it gets it
could suck it it can suck up well
interesting thing she played college
basketball for 30 years ago as it may I
said how does she still have eligibility
because she's a woman now that's what I
said German they let her they let her
transition and when you're transitioning
you go back now you're a woman you don't
have a history as playing as a woman so
now you're allowed to play again five
more years of college ability yep do I
feel like a lot more time gonna do this
there's a few that would do it a hundred
percent know Dana White was joking
around about that like I know a few guys
if it could be a world champion they'd
cut their dick off there's a few gone
yes some guys who that by all means
necessary
[Applause]